joe biden avait qualifié le 6 janvier
2021 com est l'un des jours les plus
sombres de l'histoire américaine
cette phrase résume à elle seule la
perception de ces événements notamment
dans les rangs démocrates
nombreux sont ceux à avoir réclamé des
sanctions exemplaires et très rapidement
certains demandé à ce que les
responsables de ces immeubles soient
poursuivis pour sédition un crime
fédéral sévèrement punis aux états unis
nous envisageons de retenir des crimes
majeurs comme la sédition et la
conspiration pas plus tard qu'hier
notre bureau a organisé une cellule
composée de procureurs de la sécurité
nationale de très haut niveau et de
procureurs de la corruption publique
dont les seuls ordres de marche de ma
part son de monter des accusations de
sédition et de conspiration liée aux
actes les plus odieux qui ont eu lieu au
capitole il s'agit d'accusations
importante qui comporte des crimes avec
des peines de prison allant jusqu'à 20
en un an plus tard 727 personnes au
moins ont été arrêtées mais jusqu'à
présent aucune poursuites pour sédition
n'a été engagée officiellement les juges
estiment qu'il s'agit d'une charge
difficile à établir finalement parmi les
personnes arrêtées certaines l'ont été
pour avoir pénétré à l'intérieur du
capitole ou pour des violences sur des
représentants des forces de l'ordre mais
une grande majorité est en fait
poursuivis pour des délits mineurs tels
que trouble à l'ordre public en plus de
ces poursuites une commission d'enquêté
a été formée au sein de la chambre des
représentants
face à l'opposition des républicains
elle est quasi exclusivement composée de
démocrates
son but tenter de réunir des preuves sur
l'implication de donald trump dans ces
émeutes une thèse que le principal
intéressé a toujours démenti
je ne pardonnerai jamais au président
ancien président des états unis et à ses
lacs et ses bruts qui l'a envoyé au
capitole
il s'agit honteusement de la plus grande
chasse aux sorcières c'est ce qu'ils
font il vaut mieux ciblés je suis pris
pour cible depuis le début de ma
présidence
l'omniprésence de ce sujet dans les
médias et les passes d'armes entre les
démocrates et les républicains ne font
qu'accentuer la fracture dans le pays
les enquêtes d'opinion se succèdent et
conduisent au même constat celui d'une
amérique qui se déchirent sur ces sujets
sept électeurs républicains sur 10
disent encore considéré joe biden comme
un président est légitime la perception
de la journée du 6 janvier et également
très différentes selon les opinions
politiques alors qu'une écrasante
majorité de démocrates considèrent ces
événements comme très violent pour la
plupart des républicains cette journée
était peu ou pas du tout violence
d'ailleurs certains manifestants
affirment aujourd'hui que si c'était à
refaire il retournerait au capitole pour
faire entendre leur colère